the air moves backwards and forwards
like that across a room i would
say and moves in some kind of wave
pattern across the room and it will hit
your eardrum and vibrate something which
turns it into some kind of electrical
signal which your brain decodes and you
go oh that's that note or that's that
note
when we come to get that sound into a
computer the simplest way would be to
have
a microphone which basically turns sound
into some kind of voltage very
badly drawn wave like that but what i'm
interested is is how
once that voltage gets down the cable
you can put it into something like a
sound card
here's one that i've got sitting up here
i've actually got a few lying around and
they
convert what would be an analog signal
something coming through a
guitar lead or a microphone cable and
they'll turn it into something that a
computer can use which is basically ones
and zeros a digital signal
there are two numbers that you associate
with
a wave file one of which is called
the bit depth and then you've got
another thing which is called the sample
frequency
so basically these are the two
parameters you
use to convert an analog signal
to a digital signal i'll start with the
sample frequency the one i'll write down
second
um and that is basically the number of
times per second
that the computer will stab in and go
what is this level here so if we say
you know there's a number of different
levels you know one going up to whatever
this axis here is time and it will go
across here and
stab in there and go that's the level at
that point and that's the level at that
point and that's the level at that point
and it will record these as numbers so
you might get like five
six eight so the number of slices per
second that it does
is the sample frequency and obviously
the more of those you put in per second
in theory the better quality the audio
is going to be
now for a big wave like this you don't
need a particularly high
sample frequency because what you're
getting there are
tiny little details you could probably
stab in
two or three times in each cycle but
obviously if you start to get a wave
that's much more
like that if you only sampled there and
then the next sample you took with a
you're going to miss
all of that data there it's just going
to end up cutting off what you
consider the treble the high frequencies
so the higher notes would just be cut
off
i'm talking about physical high
frequency data so
talking about high notes like like
screechy notes you know if you like run
your
you have two bits of glass scraping
against each other it produces a really
high frequency which hurts your ears
that is a real top end note and
something that's like a
real low sonic boom sort of note that's
a real low frequency because it
physically has a longer wavelength and
the high end frequencies have a really
short wavelength now we only hear
up to around 22
000 hertz so that we call that 22k
but there's the two main industry
standards that we use
are 44.1 okay
and 48 k and when i say k that's
thousand cycles
per second i'm going to put in the
kilohertz there so the reason that 44.1
was initially
chosen because it's a strange number
that isn't it 44.1 i mean where does
that come from
basically the highest that they measured
at the time i mean i i don't know the
exact science of this i'll probably be
corrected but the highest that people
thought
people could hear was 22 050
hertz and to get the full cycle
of a 22 050 wave you need to
double the sampling frequency they
picked
44 100 hertz as the sample frequency to
be able to recreate anything that we can
hear as human beings
for various reasons that got changed for
video
so cds and audio mp3s and other such
things
generally come out that cds definitely
do and mp3s most of the time come out at
44.1
and if you put a dvd or a blu-ray in
your player
you will be listening to audio at 48k so
computers
and other devices you know digital hi-fi
amps other stuff like that
need to be readily available to convert
between
those now there's other people nowadays
who use 96k
some microphones can't hear as high as
the human ear so maybe they're not
picking anything up above 16k
so sampling at 44.1 or 48k is
well above what you need to pick up the
sound from that particular microphone
now the second thing is the bit depth
and the bit depth is the one that to me
does make quite uh an
important difference so when you get a
final product
on a cd or you get it on a dvd or a
blu-ray or something like that most of
the audio is at 16 bits which basically
means that between the top level of the
plus here
and the bottom level of the minus there
the levels that you can have the
different volume levels that you can
have
you can only have at 16 bits 65
536 you'd think that's enough different
levels
but realistically it's kind of half that
because you're dealing with a wave here
it comes down below the center line
and comes back above so really you're
getting half of that and half of that so
you get half of 65
536 above and half of that below with
the zero line in the middle
so you probably think that thirty
two and a bit thousand i'm not going to
do the exact math 32 and a bit thousand
levels would be enough and for
a final piece of finished music that
that is kind of mastered and ready to go
out it probably is which is why that's
why we get
you know that's the cd standard that's
the dvd standard
but when you're actually dealing with
the individual instruments you might end
up with a drummer who's
playing really loudly and hitting away
really loudly
and then right at the end he's just
doing a little cymbal swell and there's
the tiniest little amount of volume
going on and you just want that volume
to stay
right to the end till the symbol stops
ringing and unfortunately when you're
dealing with those raw
files that haven't been mixed and
there's not a lot of other things going
on
if you record at 16 bit you can really
hear it being grainy because it's all
very well
saying when you're dealing with a wave
that's like that you've got
loads and loads and loads and loads and
loads i mean you could have 32 and a bit
thousand levels there to deal with
if the wave that you're dealing with
suddenly becomes only
that big you're only dealing with
that amount of the space so this is
maybe
the the drummer hitting i don't know a
symbol really hard there at the
beginning
and then it dies out yeah and 10 seconds
after you've hit the symbol it's it's
died out and it's become really quiet
and you want to
pick up that noise as as perfectly as
possible without it becoming
distorted and fuzzy because what ends up
happening is you end up
creating a wave and you get all these
points and then when the computer puts
it out
it puts them as points and then it's got
draw lines between these points
and if you haven't got enough levels you
end up with
effectively square waves which don't
sound particularly nice they said
you get quite a buzzy sound to them so
if you hear
right on the end of a fade out of a
track and you turn it up really loud in
your hi-fi you might be able to hear
the song starting to get a bit a bit
dizzy and a bit fizzy at the top end
and that's effectively what's happening
here so when you're doing recording if
you're trying to record a drum kit and
then a guitar and then a vocal
and and going through and actually
layering up as a song
you generally want to be recording at 24
bits
so for a 24 bit signal we end up with 16
million
777 thousand two hundred and sixteen
different levels which is why on a
professional level you record everything
at 24 bit and you do your mixing and
generally within the audio software
it passes it from one place to another
actually at 32 bits you've got even more
headroom to move so head rooms like
space
yeah space because um let's say you've
got
a wave there and then you've got another
wave here
and you add the two together in a piece
of software it's going to produce a wave
that's a lot bigger
now if that is hitting the top and the
bottom there and that's hitting the top
and the bottom there
what does happen what ends up happening
is they get squared off
you'd add them together and that might
be bigger like that and then that would
just be cut off the top and that be cut
off the button because these become
no-go areas for the software because you
can't get a number that's bigger than
the amount of bits so you end up with a
wave that's like that and then it
squares off
and then it comes down and it squares
off and then it goes back up and it
squares off and it sounds distorted
so so should we give one example of how
that might sound so i'm going to get you
to say hello
hello right so that sounded horrendous
in my ears
that's called digital clipping when you
use a digital audio workstation
you're summing together wav files
constantly because you might have a bass
drum mic a snare drum mic a hi-hat mic
two or three tom mics two overheads two
room mics a bass guitar
two guitars vocals whatever so you could
have 24
36 70 50 odd tracks of information and
with backing vocals
and you're summing them all together and
the idea being is if you've been a good
engineer
you will have recorded them with enough
level that
you're not keeping the level like that
because you don't want the level really
small because it will sound grainy as we
previously discussed
but you want to send them in with enough
headroom as well so that they don't clip
but when you sum all these things
together if you've got things that are
only a little bit off the top
suddenly you're going to produce a
signal which is far in excess of what
24 bit is capable of doing so internally
within the programs they're passing the
wave files at 32 32-bit
to make up for the fact that you're
summing these all together and then the
idea being is
some piece of software at the end will
show you that it's clipping and you put
in a plug-in and turn the whole
volume down on the whole thing to get it
back so your final output
ends up still sitting within the
boundaries of what 24 bit is now
realistically if you go the tiniest
amount
over what it is and you get the tiniest
amount of digital clipping you know if
you were recording a drum kit and one
snare hit
goes slightly over you're not going to
stop the whole recording
but if you were recording a guitar and
all the way through the whole thing was
just squaring everything off
it might sound pretty nasty
so you have to make these kind of
fundamental decisions what is going to
be your sample frequency and what is
going to be your bit rate
and generally for most applications
you'd be using 24 bits
and 48k or possibly 44.1
you end up with all sorts of annoying
artifacts when you're converting from
one thing to another you're either down
scaling or upscaling you're either
throwing away data or you're adding in
data and you're having to artificially
make the data so converting between
48k and 44.1 vice versa
it's not the bulk stuff you hear it's
the the symbols and the real higher end
frequencies the treble stuff
that's where you're going to lose the
detail by doing that but there's great
algorithms out there that do all that
kind of stuff i don't
i just run it through my software click
the button it does it
we'd like to thank whispersync for voice
and amazon and audible innovation
for sponsoring this episode of computer
file do you wish you had more time to
read
you know that point where you're really
a good bit in the book but somebody
rings or
a reminder goes off or your alarm goes
off and you just have to leave
well whisper sync for voice means you
can stop reading and switch to listening
to your book
at exactly the same point that you've
just left off find out more at
amazon.com
computer file when you buy the kindle
book you just select add audible
companion
you can add narration to over 60 000
kindle bestsellers
and popular titles just check out
amazon.com
computer valve for the full list thanks
once again to them for sponsoring
computer file
this and your is what would normally be
your compass heading so it's
your your uh your magnetic compass
heading the phone can detect all of
those
aspects the trick is then how we pass
information to the plane itself